and this is the thing that's so amazing
about it yes I destroyed the BBC well of
course I did because I'm smarter than
all of them but why should I have to
rely on my wit and intellect to destroy
BBC with their research team and their
plan their deliberate plan to try and
annihilate my not only my credibility
but my life they are trying to put me
back in jail these people they're not
they're not dishonest
so why should I even sit there and
entertain them I believe I could slip
every single Sucker Punch they throw at
me for the rest of human time like I sit
with any of these clowns and no matter
who they sit with with their research
team whatever garbage they come up with
I'll make a fool of all of them but why
am I even entertaining them anymore
what's the point that was the last
chance I gave mainstream media they lied
for months to get that interview with me
completely dishonest head to toe and
like you said they sit with Philip are
you okay are you okay we heard your
mom's upset that poor old lady maybe
everyone should stop talking about it
because his mom's upset let's not talk
about it anymore because his mother's
old you're either part of the club or
not you have to sell your sanity
nowadays if you sell your sanity your
afforded protections that's the reality
of it because if you're a same thinking
person you don't buy their and that's
what upsets them they don't want anybody
who thinks for themselves they need you
to not they want you to believe exactly
what's on the television screen believe
in covid it's covet now it's covered now
oh Putin's invaded Ukraine Putin's cured
covet now now it's it's insane until the
next thing comes it's absolutely asinine
did any of the questions that they sent
you ahead of time by the way we didn't
there was no no okay danelva I need to
pause this for one second just to tell
you that there's some of them made an
account called denalva de Nova Janella
someone in the chat made account called
denalva de Navidad oh that's cute you
know I must say guys don't give her more
attention but it's a good thing you know
what I mean when even when Jenny did all
of her videos about me I'm like wow is
that really like how much like my
presence hits people yeah I know I
actually put a video on you too
the hair you look completely different
and you're way nicer in person she's a
nice person I look like a [__] but I'm
actually really nice you look on camera
you do but you are actually a real
sweetheart what a surprise yeah I know
most people get surprised they're like
oh wow I don't mean to understand
more than Elvis Pearl trying to get your
attention
whatsoever did they ask you any of the
questions they said they were going to
ask zero they start with an attack and
it became a battle instantly did they
ask you at any point what jail was like
your mental health was like zero how
like you completely missed the mark when
everyone wants to know what was jail
like what but they don't even ask you
that question this is what's so
interesting about it these people are so
detached from reality because they are
genuinely detached in reality they think
that finding a video I made eight years
ago a four-hour speech I made eight
years ago and finding one line of it
without context that can be misconstrued
they think that's sitting down with me
and and saying that to me is an aha
moment nobody cares because they're
taken out of context one and I said
you're taking things out of context
because I'm not taking out a context I
said you're presenting it without
context that's taking it out of context
that's what it is you're lying by
Omission I said that to her after the
camera's off and she looked at me
because she didn't understand when you
omit details when you refuse to put in
all of the details you can lie by
including one detail which may happen to
be true you can tell the truth and miss
all the details around the truth and you
are lying by Omission you're lying by
omission and you're sitting here saying
oh you said this eight years ago nobody
cares because they know me and they know
I didn't mean it in that way and they
know it's taken out of context and they
know that it's an old video on the
internet and it's not even an aha moment
they think it is but they just want to
sit with you for an hour attack you and
attack you and attack you wait for you
to make one mistake if I would have
stuttered or made a single mistake
that's the only three minutes they would
have shown that's all they want they
want that one hour then they take the
little bit with me they cut it down to
12 minutes they look terrible in all of
it but I've already made a single
mistake would have been the only bit
they've shown that's all they I care
about fake news did you tell them did
you say I'm only doing this if I'm able
to record as well I said I know that's
what happened with Trump as well a
couple years ago I didn't even tell him
I just recorded it okay so they didn't
know you were recording they didn't know
I was recording until afterwards and
then I said that was dishonest I'm going
to release the whole video you told them
before you released there is no contract
or agreement with BBC no nothing was
signed it was just simply a an interview
okay because I think that was very
important when you released it for
people to see what fully was said versus
and by the way you know the Phillip
Schofield the interview that they put up
the 12-minute one that just came out you
know the comments are turned off of
course they are the comments are turned
off yours are turned on this is turned
off uh and and who knows many reasons
why they would do that but go back go
back to BBC so okay they come they want
to ask the questions of you for some of
the people that maybe aren't following
the story closely but they know who you
are we're in the car we're driving and a
lot of people are asking questions we
asked the drivers like hey are you going
to Tate's Place how do you know we're
going to takes place and he says well
who State oh Andrew Tate oh tell us what
I entertain well they said okay what
kind of a guy is he he's actually really
like him I said why do things going
through what he's going through right
now oh it's because it's always because
of money okay so we're at a different
restaurant so tell us why are you going
through this why is it going everybody's
saying a similar thing about this right
but for those who don't know there's
three different camps yeah the camp that
already sees you guilty it doesn't
matter what they read so for example
this story here you know from BBC came
out just last night 10 30. Andrew Tate
choked me until I passed that UK woman
claims right this is Alice another
anonymous name just like Sophie right
but there's three camps there's those
that say well look I'm already thinking
he's guilty I don't like him anyways I
need anything to get me to think he's
guilty whatever it takes I don't have to
I don't have to do my own due diligence
I just have to hear anything then
there's a camp that's a die-hard fan
there's nothing you can do that they did
wrong you can you know in their eyes
gonna be wrong then you have the people
in the middle that are the reasonable
ones that are saying you know what let
me look at this what about this what
about that the people in the middle may
say the following question they may say
and I may have asked this question from
you last time as well they may say
Andrew okay if this guy is so innocent
how can they get you to go to the
dungeon for 92 days how can they put you
on house arrest how can they do all this
stuff if you're somebody that was born
in the U.S you lived in UK how come
somebody else isn't coming to bail you
out you got different lawyers how is it
that they can keep doing this to you if
you're not guilty what do you say to
those people yeah and once again I have
to be careful what I say because of the
court case but Romania has a law or the
law in Romania is basically if you can
prove to a judge that it might have
happened they're allowed to hold you up
to six months during the investigation
stage if I was guilty of anything I
would have been charged long ago and
we're going to talk about charges soon
because I I still believe they're going
to attempts to charge me but we're now
approaching the end of the six months
they can keep me under a form of arrest
without charge
typically in Romania when I was first
arrested
the guard said ah within two weeks
you'll have your indictment it was like
two weeks he goes yeah everyone gets
charged quickly nobody Waits six months
for a charge if they arrest you they
charge you like like every other country
right the fact they've waited six months
and gone into my entire life and
attempted to to find something shows
they don't have a case why I believe it
happened is because they didn't have a
case when they were trying to hit me
with this garbage and they thought you
know what if we put him all over the
news
if we slander his name completely if we
there was
there was girls to hurt my undertake
call this number in the UK
so they were attempting to use the
to find what they wanted months go by
months go by months go by case File is
empty nothing's happening my lawyer's
saying when we can close this case File
like yeah we're just waiting for some
papers we're gonna close it we're going
to close we're going to close it around
the time I was canceled
things start appearing in the case File
again they start spying on me again
very interesting that it happened around
that time
I don't know if they understood that I
didn't have I wasn't protected by the
political class of the USA I don't know
what happened
they started to build this case and they
spied on me for all of these months
spending millions of Euros spying on me
everywhere I went trying to find
evidence of the crime
eventually they get to the end of their
legal limit spy on me and they don't
have any crime they don't have anything
so in my current court case we have two
Americans who lied the ones who we have
the conversations between them saying
they're going to an Oscar for lying to
the police we have the CCTV of them
coming and going we have their Uber
records showing they can travel the
country freely we have their phone calls
with their mother where they're saying
yeah he didn't hurt me and my boyfriend
called me did we have all of it we
we have those two
and then there's nobody else who could
possibly even take the stand I don't
believe as as as high level as this
Matrix attack is I still don't believe a
Romanian judge is going to put me in
jail with the dossiers I've seen it it's
garbage I don't think I'm gonna end up
in jail but it's just taking years of my
life damaging my influence to having bad
things to say about me keeping me under
control keeping me locked in a house
that's all they want to do they have no
interest in the truth there's no victims
there's no one to take the stand do you
know who Sophie is or Alice is or no
yeah so the BB's silly that's really
interesting so then the BBC says well we
found victims because the BBC have done
enough investigative journalism to
understand that the case is garbage and
they have there's no victim so they said
well we found victims
they found one called Sophie first that
was a few months ago I think I was still
in jail when Sophie appeared is that her
real name no that's her thing so they
have a girl with a fake name called
Sophie they don't show her face
they they ask me what do you think about
Sophie how can I comment on Sophie when
Sophie isn't real first firstly you've
made her up secondly I don't know who
you're talking about you're saying that
nine years ago I was emotionally
controlling that is the most subjective
garbage accusation what does that mean
nine years ago I said you shouldn't
party with those guys in the club is
that what I said I don't know what I
said I don't know who she is if she
exists at all and they're saying nine
years ago you're emotionally controlling
Sophie said so who's Sophie we're not
telling you what's emotionally
controlling mean we're not telling them
what comment do you want if this person
even exists which they don't then I
destroy the BBC make it very clear to
them that Sophie doesn't exist on repeat
because she doesn't and two days later
Alice appears what's interesting about
this is that decal the federal agency
inside of Romania along with help from
International Partners have tried so
hard spending millions of Euros with
Federal level tools to find a victim so
they can put me in jail and they can't
find anyone but the BBC just pulls them
up whenever they want the BBC does where
do these people come from and I say this
every single time if anybody believes
they've been wronged male or female by
me go to the police go to the police I
encourage you to go to the police all
these people say we don't want to go to
the police
we just want to say on the news what is
that because you're not real is that why
that's pretty convenient I mean if I was
a bad person why don't you go to the
calls oh because you have no evidence
and it doesn't exist that's why are all
these accusers in the UK not even in
Romania not even Romania so Sophie and
Alice is supposedly both from the UK and
Alice's story to correct that's not Al I
said Alice it's Evie Evie or Evie or
something like that e-v-i-e it's all
made up names it's all made up yes
Evie is saying 13 years ago I choked her
or something yeah by the way when is the
six month time limit and did this come
okay and can we reference the Tweet you
just posted a couple days ago I want to
stay on the show it's commenting on Evie
and you were going to say something
about Evie uh what she said 10 so she's
claiming 10 years ago or 13 years ago
you guys had the consensual sex the
first time she comes back for the second
time around according to the story she
says she was being uh uh your hand was
on her throat strangled me she was
passed out for a minute and then she
came back and she said I did not approve
of the second time time having sex after
she was passed out so these stories
they're making you know and then she
says the guy asks a question and saying
how come you didn't do any police report
back then he says well because it's not
fully rape and it's not bad because it
was consensual I kind of wanted to be
there and I didn't tell anybody about it
six years later there's way too many
things that doesn't give it credibility
for somebody to say I didn't do anything
about it then but six years later I told
my friends three or six years later yeah
and this is the thing that's scary if
you say to any red-blooded male 13 years
ago you had sex with a woman
consensually and she's now unhappy about
how that sex happened you can get any
man on that Earth can get screwed to
that if this person exists at all like
you said get in line baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah there would be a lot of there would
be a lot of complaints bro listen when
have you ever heard what have you ever
met a girl and she's like I love my ex
he was a great guy it just didn't work
out
no toxic he was a narcissist he abused
me he kicked my dog you know it's just
endless endless smear and that like I
get so much Flack when I don't like just
automatically believe a girl it's crazy
if you even quite like if someone's
story just doesn't make sense like this
one girl oh my gosh she just got
divorced right and she had this whole
story about how the like the husband
left her high and dry and she went off
to us like like and she took the kid
because he was a deadbeat and then she
would say oh but I didn't trash him and
I'm like well how did you not track him
you just called him a deadbeat and all I
said on social media was we should
really hear his side of the story and
Destiny all these big streamers started
coming at me yeah and say thing that
like that I'm I just all you do is only
hear them hear the woman's side I'm like
I heard her side I watched the 45 minute
video she made about her ex-boyfriend
and I almost think we should believe
people less that do that stuff because
it's very like attention seeking yeah
because they've learned because the
thing is this too like that used to be
all the rage like the 80s and the 90s
like one woman came out and started
crying and then you got these evil
[__] at home like I hate my husband
like I can [__] I could do this too
and then now they all like I said copy
pasta do you know one thing I also
realized that if Andrew hate wasn't like
um a celebrity if he wasn't famous I
don't think this woman would actually
come out because you know what the world
we're leaving right now everyone wants
to be famous everyone wants in any way
they can so it's like when you get
famous people just come up and make up a
lot of stories sometimes yeah they're
true so if because he was a let's say he
was a Debbie back then in the day why
didn't she complain but all of a sudden
now he's famous everyone knows him on
YouTube all of a sudden you remember oh
my God that helped me past that I want
to go say something to the police oh now
I'm angry he chokes me you will die
[Music]
I know that maybe it might be true but
then again it's like they're taking
advantage that's what people would see
us even if it does happen it's like I'll
feel bad for them but then I'm feeling
like you're just taking advantage of
this man dude you're doing it for what
you're getting out of it because if you
are genuinely sad about what happened to
you you would say something and and all
the Western world as well where you can
say that the Lord favors the women in
the western world and it does favor that
women outside so if this happened like
let's say like this happened in Nigeria
I feel like a lot of women would not say
nothing because they're like people are
going to be like look at you less but
this is a Western World people just if
you go say something to the police the
women are always right so like that's
what I think that's like that's what it
just happens in general it just happens
it happened to Pearl when she popped off
everybody from her past is like oh Pearl
is terrible to me happened to me
recently some lose user that I took into
my life felt sorry for tried to lift
them up now he wants to try to like
expose me because he's a loser English
teacher you know all this stuff happens
when people rise to the top
right and you have people in your past
who feel jealous or they feel angry that
they weren't able to ride your coattails
up to fame or Glory they get entitled
they feel entitled like you were started
in the same place and then you became
successful so then it's like they get
like jealous and then it's like they had
all these issues with you but not when
you were not when you were present
that's not when you're president and
that's the thing it's like we're so
quick to believe people that like tell a
story online when you realize it's like
attention seeking especially people that
make like a full is one thing if it
comes up in a conversation you know like
within the age of live stream like stuff
comes up right yeah but I'm like this
girl made a 45 minute video about her
ex-husband and then she's like well I
had to I'm a public figure no you don't
you didn't you said like any any like
words that I've ever said about like an
ex-boyfriend online I have regretted
saying because I'm just like I shouldn't
have said anything even with anything
even with Crowder's wife like she was
sitting on that footage what was that
from 2021 yeah two years ago and she's
like okay now I'm spited now I'm gonna
release this out of nowhere like come on
well and it's and a lot of times it's
the same story like and that's why when
she was saying he was a deadbeat I
didn't believe it because again and and
you know people say it's anecdotal but
like you start to notice patterns and I
start doing this divorce documentary
where I interview men that like don't
get custody to the kit of the kids and
it's so common where the woman says he's
a deadbeat when really she's not letting
them like I think it's a myth the
deadbeat dad I think it's much more
common for women to use the kids as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible